depuis le début de la pandémie les parcs
du québec ont été pris d'assaut par une
nouvelle clientèle de nombreux sentiers
ont subi des dommages et des milieux
fragiles ont été mises à mal on doit
maintenant se poser la question comment
concilier la protection de la nature
avec ce besoin légitime de prendre l'air
[Musique]
voudrait que c'est dans les plus beaux
parcs du québec c'est un parc avec une
vallée incroyable on ne la rivière
malbaie le qui traverse le parc
également
et puis on a des amériques halperin sont
assis les particuliers
[Musique]
au parc national des hautes gorges de la
rivière malbaie cette équipe de la
société des établissements de plein air
du québec
la sépaq entreprend une longue et dure
ascension
[Musique]
avec un dénivelé de 800 m ce sentier de
5,6 km mène à un sommet qui offre une
vue sont pareils
on se trouve au sommet est numéro 3 de
l'acropole des draveurs donc si notre
sentiment d'être au paradis ou gorges de
la rivière malbaie
depuis le début de la pandémie se sentit
attire un nombre record de randonneurs
en 2020 près de cinquante mille
marcheurs ont gravi l'acropole des
draveurs une hausse de 19% par rapport
aux années précoces vide on a senti
qu'il y avait beaucoup d'effervescence
dans le pays je voudrais que on s'est
rendu compte aussi qu'on avait affaire à
une clientèle un peu différente une
bonne chose on s'entend on est les
québécois qui sont de plus en plus à
l'extérieur on est content mais c'est
sûr qu'il faut apprendre à gérer cet
achalandage accru le auquel je pense que
personne n'attendait
et c'est partout pareil dans l'ensemble
du réseau des parcs nationaux du québec
qui a connu une hausse de fréquentation
historique
s'explique en partie grâce à l'arrivée
d'une nouvelle clientèle
quinze pour cent des détenteurs de
laissez-passer annuelles n'avaient
jamais visité un parc national au québec
auparavant
c'est certain que pour beaucoup il y
avait autant d'activités que je pense
qu'on constate de plus en plus aussi que
le fait d'aller dans la nature d'être
dans la forêt c'est bon pour notre santé
mentale et physique
donc les gens ont vu se reconnecter avec
la nature et pense que certains ont pris
goût à as of
mais tout cela n'est pas sans
conséquence
on a constaté qu'il y avait peut-être
plus de gens qui avaient tendance à
sortir des sentiers de faire des
raccourcis
donc ils détruisent la végétation par au
passage c'est des gens qui sont
peut-être moins habitués au niveau de la
préservation des milieux naturels
les sommets sont parmi les destinations
les plus prisées des randonneurs et ce
sont aussi des endroits très sensible 5
milieu arctique alpin donc vous voyez on
est être un sol rocailleux les
conditions à son difficile pour que la
vie énergie si donc on a dit on et des
plantes arctique alpine qu'on souhaite
protéger l'ex entassés et qui peuvent
être assez rare puis on a du week-end
aussi le qui se trouve un peu partout
sur les sommets mais on sait que les
lichens ça pousse à peu près à points 5
mm un millimètre par année afin que l'on
puisse imaginer c'est hyper fragile
une grosse botte des randonneurs qui est
qui détruit le lichen c'est
catastrophique pour nous
concilier la conservation des milieux
naturels tout en les rendant accessibles
au plus grand nombre est un défi
constant depuis le début de la pandémie
en europe et aux états unis les parcs
ont aussi été pris d'assaut dès que les
conditions sanitaires l'ont permis chez
nous un sondage de l'organisme sentier
transcanadien révèle que l'utilisation
des sentiers a augmenté de 50% au pays
ça c'est vous laisser passer les maths
sur un sac à même préoccupation du côté
du parc d'environnement naturel de
sutton en estrie un endroit recherché
par les randonneurs on est tous pas
accueille 500 malades et parler derrière
moi me suis bien senti principal depuis
le début de la pandémie la forte hausse
de l'achalandage est devenu un véritable
casse tête
par une belle journée à l'automne 2000
vingt mille sept cents personnes se sont
présentées au minuscule kiosque
d'accueil du jamais vu tu avais un line
up qui descendait et quasiment jusqu'à
la station de ce qu'il sait les gens
étaient stationnés en parallèle tous
partout on a juste de toilette on a des
fils qui débordent sur la rue puis là on
ne comprend pas vraiment ce qui se passe
on est un tout petit organisme on n'a
pas beaucoup de staff on n'a pas
beaucoup de ressources puis là on se dit
oh mon dieu qu'est-ce qu'on va faire
c'était c'était du délire total ce flot
de nouveaux visiteurs a engendré son lot
de problèmes
sait on se promenait dans la montagne si
on est à sutton pitt avait l'impression
d'être sur le mont royal s'est fait que
c'était pas nécessairement ça que tu
avais envie de vivre dans le bois
patricia lefebvre peine à reconnaître
certains de ces sentiers d'une manière
générale les sentiers se sont dégradées
parce que les gens ne restait pas dans
les sentiers on avait anticipé un peu le
problème parce que la combinaison de
plein de monde plus les deux mètres de
distanciation nous nos sentiers il a à
peu près un mètre de large avec
évidemment tu peux pas croiser quelqu'un
à 2 mètres sur 1 santé qui fait un mètre
de large donc les gens fatalement ils
piétinaient les abords si on regarde en
arrière de deux mois on voit très bien
finalement qu'est-ce qui s'est passé là
le sentier initiale ils étaient entre
l'arbre qui est debout et l'arbre qui
est tombé ça c'était le sentier tel
qu'il était à banco vide il faisait à
peu près 1 mètre de large à force de
passer à gauche ça casse et les racines
puis elle sentiers rendu à peu près à
trois mètres de large du coup l'eau
quand t'es cool et coule sur 3 m de
large au lieu de couler sur un mètre de
large fait que là ça amène de la terre
hélas etc c'est comme un prof c'est
exponentiel
pour stopper la dégradation des sentiers
et éviter l'érosion les responsables du
parc ont mis en place des sens unique
ils ont installé des clôtures et
instaurer des quotas pour contrôler le
nombre de visiteurs mais est-ce que ce
sera suffisant
ce que j'espère aussi c'est que ça va
inciter le gouvernement les
gouvernements à créer beaucoup plus de
parcs et d'endroits où les gens puissent
aller se promener parce qu'on s'est
rendu compte à quel point c'était
important pour le monde puis à quel
point finalement ils n'avaient pas assez
au parc national des hautes gorges de la
rivière malbaie on a pris les grands
moyens pour protéger les sommets
[Musique]
ce matin on s'affaire à transporter du
matériel destiné à l'acropole du draveur
[Musique]
on installer des poteaux des codes pour
mieux délimiter les limites du sentier
on veut éviter que les gens sortent sans
type et piétine la végétation on veut
concentrer l'impact finalement qu'on a à
un seul endroit et non pour faire en
sorte que tous les semis souhait soit
piétinée ici comme dans les autres parcs
nationaux on a aussi ajouté de la
signalisation et limiter le nombre de
visiteurs ça a été une bonne idée parce
que ça fait en sorte qu'un site comme
ici le semaine montagne est très prisé
il ya eu beaucoup de monde il ya eu
beaucoup de monde à peu près à tous les
jours mais n'y a jamais eu trop de monde
en même temps
n'empêche la sépaq n'a pas l'intention
de baisser la garde
et c'est grâce à des photos prises par
des drones qu'elle compte assurer la
préservation des sommets fragile
en fait sur leurs taux photo ça ne fasse
ça va nous donner une image une image
aérienne de très haute résolution on est
capable de voir les impacts que les
randonneurs vont avoir en piétinant la
végétation sensibilité
là on est capable de prendre vraiment de
l'altitude littéralement parlant et de
voir là une vue d'ensemble du secteur
donc au lieu d'avoir des endroits très
précis on mesure l'impact pétillement on
le voit dans son ensemble avec le ch
elle lui il garde en banque le plan de
vol on est capable de réaliser année
après année donc on est capable de
comparer comme les images qu'on aurait
eu 100 ans en 2019 par exemple avec
celle qu'on réalise aujourd'hui et qu'on
est capable de voir l'effet du
piétinement donc est ce qu'il ya des
endroits qui ça c'est augmenter à ce que
des endroits que ça alors régresser donc
n'était
alors plus de randonneurs c'est une
bonne nouvelle ou pas je pense que les
québécois se sont réappropriés la nature
leurs parcs nationaux et certainement
que plusieurs d'entre eux vont continuer
à venir profiter de cet environnement
l'extraordinaire
moi je suis un éternel optimiste je
pense que il y avait une première une
première vague des adeptes de plein air
qui a déferlé en 2020 mais si on
continue à a bien éduqué je pense que on
va aller on va aller dans le bon sens et
tout le monde
[Musique]